since the beginning of this pandemic
we've tried to
update you as soon as possible about
changes in the scientific data
or the analysis and so i must tell you
this afternoon that
we've been informed today that in
addition to spreading more quickly
it also now appears that there is some
evidence that the new variant the
variant that was first identified in
london and the southeast may be
associated with a higher degree
of mortality and i'm going to ask
patrick in a minute
to say a bit more about that because
it's largely
the impact of this new variant that
means the nhs
is under such intense pressure with
another forty
thousand two hundred and sixty one
positive cases
since yesterday we have thirty eight
thousand
five hundred and sixty two covered
patients now in hospital that's
78 percent higher than the first peak in
uh in april and tragically
there have been a further 1401
deaths so it's more important
than ever that we all remain vigilant in
following the rules and that we stay at
home protect the nhs
and thereby save lives
but i also want to answer a key question
i know will be
uppermost in your minds all
current evidence continues to show that
both the vaccines we're currently using
remain effective both against the
old variant and this new variant
and so you'll also want to know that our
immunization program continues
at an unprecedented rate 5.4 million
people
across the uk have now received their
first first
dose of the vaccine and over the last 24
hours we can report a record
400 000 vaccinations in england
one in 10 of all adults have received
their first dose including 71
of over 80s and two-thirds of elderly
care home residents having secured
orders for hundreds of millions of doses
the uk government has supplied vaccines
to the devolved administrations
according to population size first doses
have
been administered now to 151 000 people
in northern ireland
358 000 in scotland and 212
000 in wales and i'm glad that the
uh government of the uk the whole of the
uk is able to assist
the devolved administrations in
deploying the vaccine and i know
everyone across the country is grateful
for the logistical skill
of the british army there is much
more to do and the target uh remains
very stretching
indeed but we remain on track to reach
our goal of offering a first dose to
everyone in the
top four priority groups by the middle
of february
and i want to thank all the doctors and
nurses
especially at the gp led sites who are
vaccinating
at a phenomenal rate as well as i say as
those in our armed forces
our local authorities our pharmacies and
volunteers who are making this
extraordinary
national effort possible
and i want to thank all of you who have
come
forward to get your jabs because by
doing that
you're protecting yourselves your
communities
and of course our nhs and i say to
everyone
when that letter arrives please don't
hesitate
to book that appointment and get this
life-saving
protection because this is the best
and fastest way for us all to defeat
this virus and get our lives back to
normal
i'm not going to ask chris to do the
slides thank you prime minister
first slide please so the first slide um
is uh the office for national statistics
data
showing the estimated number of people
testing positive
for kovid 19 in england and that has
been on a steady
upward slope since the early part of
december
but i'm glad to say that in the most
recent data
there has been a turning of the corner
on that
and the number of people with infections
has gone down but it has gone down
from an exceptionally high level and
their most recent estimate
is we're still at a stage in england
where one in 55 people
have the virus so there is a definite
signs of improvement but from a very
high level remaining at a very high
level
thanks to the extraordinary work that
everybody has done together
to make sure people stay at home when
they do not need to go outside
next slide please
this then uh looks at the number of
people in hospital
uh with kovid in the uk and it is
increasing
all the time has been over the last
several weeks
and is now at an extraordinarily high
level as the prime minister has just
said
but there is now a sign of this
beginning to flatten out
uh in some parts of uh england
uh particularly the southeast the east
of england and london
there's now signs of some reduction in
the numbers going into hospital
but at an incredibly high rate still
uh in other areas there's still some
increase uh in
parts of the midlands and the north of
england for example
but overall there is now a flattening
out and we hope to see
uh following the reductions from a high
level in the number of cases
the beginnings of a reduction of cases
in hospital but this will take
some weeks to work through the system
until we start to see significant falls
in the numbers in hospital
nhs staff are working extraordinarily
hard
across the whole country because of the
ex the very very large numbers of people
in hospital
with covid next slide please
and sadly the number of people who have
had a positive test for covid
and then died shortly afterwards is
continuing to climb
and because this is uh later this this
is a delayed
effect so people get infections then
they end up going to hospital
gets more severely ill and then uh sadly
some of them die most
obviously recover the number of people
who are dying has
been steadily increasing and the most
recent seven day
rolling average uh is over a thousand
deaths
a day so this uh is a very high rate and
it again it will take
longer to come down and probably will go
up for
the over the next week because of the
fact there's a delay between people
going into hospital
and some people are sadly dying
i'll now hand over to sir patrick for
some comments about the new variant
thank you very much so there are three
major variants
of uh potential concern the one that was
first identified in the uk
one that was identified in south africa
and one that was identified
in brazil three countries all of which
sequence a lot and so pick these things
up early
i want to talk about the uk one because
it's a common variant now
comprising a significant number of the
cases
the first thing to say is that we have
confidence that this
is spreading more easily than the old
variant so we think it transmits between
30 and 70 percent more easily
than the old variant we don't yet
understand
why that is the case it doesn't have
a difference in terms of age
distribution so there's no preferential
age it can affect anybody at any age
similarly to the original variant the
original virus
but i do want to say a word about
severity and mortality
when we look at data from hospitals so
patients who are in hospital
with the virus the outcomes for those
with
the original virus or the new variant
look the same
so there's no real evidence of an
increase in mortality for those
in hospital however when data are looked
at in terms of
those who've been tested positive so
anyone who's tested positive
there is evidence that there's an
increased risk
for those who have the new variant
compared to the old virus
now that evidence is not yet strong it's
it's a series of different
bits of information that come together
to support that and i want to put it
into context as to what it might mean
but stressing that these data currently
uncertain
and we don't have a very good um
estimate of the precise nature or indeed
whether it is overall increase but it
looks like it is and i want to give some
context
if you took um somebody in their 60s a
man in their 60s
the average risk is that for a thousand
people
who got infected roughly 10
would be expected to unfortunately die
with the virus with the new variant
for a thousand people infected
roughly 13 or 14 people might be
expected to die so that's the sort of
change
for that sort of age group an increase
from 10 to 13 or 14 out of a thousand
and you will see that across the
different age groups as well a similar
sort of relative increase
in the risk so that's what we're looking
at but i want to stress
that there's a lot of uncertainty around
these numbers and we need
more work to get a precise handle on it
but it obviously is of concern that this
has
an increase in uh mortality as well as
an increase in transmissibility as it
appears
of today let me say also a word about
vaccines the first is that there's
increasing evidence from laboratory
studies
that the variant in the uk
will be susceptible to the vaccines and
so
i think that's increasing from a number
of different sources
including looking at sierra blood taken
from people who've been
vaccinated showing that it can
neutralize the
new virus and indeed just two days ago
one of the manufacturers of one of the
one of the vaccines the pfizer biontech
team the biontech team actually did
studies
showing that there was very good
neutralization
of the variant virus by the blood taken
from patients people who've been
vaccinated so i think
there's increasing confidence coupled
with i think what is a very important
clinical observation
which is that individuals who've been
infected previously
and have generated antibodies appear to
be equally protected
against original virus and new variant
so there's good clinical data as well to
support the idea that the vaccines
should be as effective against this
virus as against the old one
or there or thereabouts so i think good
news on the vaccine front
and then finally a word um just about
the south african and brazilian
variants we know less about how
much more transmissible they are we are
more concerned that they have certain
features which means
they might be less susceptible to
vaccines
we will see a lot of information coming
out from different laboratories it's
very difficult to compare
between laboratories on this data and we
need to get
more clinical information to understand
how much of an effect if any there is
on the vaccine but they are definitely
of more concern
than the one in the uk at the moment and
we need to keep looking at it
and and studying this very carefully
which is what's going on in laboratories
across the world at the moment